Чи збирається виходити з проекту "Північний потік-2"
один із його ключових учасників?
Від імені німецького енергетичного концерну Uniper на прохання DW
заяву зробив його фінансовий директор Крістофер Дельбрюк.
Напередодені низка ЗМІ з посиланням на того ж Дельбрюка повідомила, що
Uniper не виключає виходу з проекту "Північний потік-2"
у разі запровадження санкцій США для його учасників.
На думку аналітиків, якщо це станеться, по "Північному потоку-2"
буде завдано серйозного удару.
Можливо, цей удар стане початком його кінця.
- Це дуже послабить цей проект, якщо з нього почнуть іти головні інвестори, наприклад, Uniper.
Тому що саме приватні інвестиції такі необхідні, щоб
виправдати цей дорогий і економічно сумнівний газопровід.
Якщо це станеться, то це буде перший цвях у труну "Північного потоку- 2".
- Треба враховувати той факт, що цієї зими в компанії "Юніпер" змінився власник.
Майже 50% акцій отримала фінська державна енергетична компанія "Фортум".
Вона займається відновлювальною енергетикою, гідроелектростанціями,
атомними електростанціями. А ось газовий бізнес її особливо не цікавить.
Це не значить, що вона буде примушувати "Юніпер" відмовлятися від газового бізнесу,
але я підозрюю, що спеціально боротися за якісь газові проекти вона теж не буде.
Прокладка труб газогону по дну Балтійського моря вже триває,
незважаючи на критику з різних сторін.
Проект планують завершити до кінця 2019 року.
Окрім німецького Uniper, європейськими партнерами "Газпрому" в "Північному потоці-2"
є французький Engie, британсько-нідерландська Royal Dutch Shell,
австрійський OMV і німецька Wintershall.
"Північний потік-2" був однією з головних тем переговорів
Анґели Меркель з Володимиром Путіним улітку цього року.
Німеччина зацікавлена в поставках російського газу і виступає проти будь-яких санкцій.
Водночас Берлін враховує жорсткий спротив, який проект викликав у деяких країнах ЄС,
а також у США. Критики "Північного потоку-2"
передусім вказують на те, що він має політичне підґрунтя, що нова гілка трубопроводу
посилить залежність Європи від "Газпрому" і зашкодить Україні як транзитеру російського газу.
Москва запевняє, що проект суто економічний.
Берлін зі свого боку вимагає від Москви гарантій продовження транзиту через Україну.
Водночас у гру вступив Вашингтон, який хоче постачати
більше власного зрідженого газу до Європи.
США оголосили про санкції проти інженерних фірм і фінансових організацій,
які співпрацюють з компанією Nord Stream 2.
Штрафні заходи пообіцяли запровадити у найближчі тижні.